battlefield is known for having some of
the most varied multiplayer maps of any
shooter series
some of them are close quarters perfect
for chaotic engagements
while others are super large
battlegrounds that encourage vehicular
and long range combat
in this video we're going to break down
the 12 largest battlefield maps the
franchise has to offer with the chart
that was shared on twitter by senior
dice designer
nicholas ostrand now before we dive into
the good stuff
do me a favor and sub to this channel
i'm gonna be throwing up battlefield
videos left and right in eager
anticipation for battlefield 2042
and trust me when i say there is a lot
to be excited about
let's dive in starting the list off at
number 12 is operation market garden a
battlefield 1942 map that is meant to
replicate the real historical battle
that occurred
in the netherlands you play as either
the german forces on the axis side or as
the usa on the ally side
the u.s forces start their base on an
allied airfield and take their battle
into the center of the map where the
main village is located
here's a fun fact the u.s forces are
able to spawn by
actually parachuting close to one of the
bases by a church
the allies get to utilize this aerial
combat but the axis forces have no
planes at their disposal
with extra tanks available instead
battlefield 1 is next on our list with
the sinai desert map
the map is set within the sinai
peninsula during the raid on viral
mazzar in the british sinai and
palestine campaign
some notable characteristics include the
behemoth a gameplay mechanic introduced
in battlefield 1.
for the cyanide desert map the behemoth
takes the form of an
armored train there is the rural hilltop
town of mazad
near the head of a canyon which is
composed of a network of streets
alleyways and fortifications all
surrounded by distinct adobe structures
a significant number of firefights take
place in this vicinity
looking past the town there's almost
nothing but vast
uninterrupted desert planes meaning
on-foot combat is almost guaranteed to
be a bad
idea the desert is ultimately
featureless making infantry stick out on
the horizon
like a sore thumb a perfect target for
scout class players
the map is meant to be a prime
battleground for aircrafts tanks
and especially cavalry units
another old school battlefield game
appears on the list and battlefield 2
will appear a good number of times for
having some of the franchise's largest
maps
the dragon valley was a minshan mountain
range in china
and was also vehicle based with the us
carrier being in a position for air
support but the harbor nearby for ground
troop deployment
the battles usually ended up with the
american team making long
and grueling pushes up the valley
speaking of which that valley is
incredibly narrow despite this map being
large as hell it's a very elongated
valley that goes through various river
villages
docks and capture points scattered
across the islands
dragon valley was also remade for
battlefield 4 and the recreation is
pretty cool and faithful to the original
battlefield 5's panzerstorm was the
first post-launch map
part of the overture chapter in the
tides of war expansion
the map depicts the german invasion of
belgium a tank battle on the western
front in world war ii
is meant to reflect the real life battle
of hanut the map takes on what seems
like an unremarkable agricultural area
outside of hanut and capture points are
in small isolated buildings that are
connected by dirt roads in a shallow
stream
there's a grid of vast largely open
fields that are bordered by walls beside
the original tank wreckage
the fields only slope up gradually so
there's extremely little cover between
the checkpoints meaning a lot of long
range engagements
similar to the cyanide desert the
reasoning here is to place a heavy
emphasis on vehicular combat although in
panzerstorm's case it's like
99 tanks given it the claim of being one
of the biggest ever battlefield tank
maps
since up to 17 tanks can roam the map at
once
fush pass is a large settlement of
various camps and guard posts nestled at
the base of a wide mountain ridge
there are coal mines complete with
chimney stacks near the west side of the
map
you have lookout points by the mountain
and even a power plant facility towards
the eastern side
and both the usmc and china teams start
with their home base on an airfield
the chinese airfield is in the southwest
whereas the us airfield is on the
opposite northeastern side
el alamein was a battle during the
western desert campaign between the
german forces and the british
marking a turning point in the fight for
egypt the map in the game is huge with
two main bases on each side of a giant
ridge
the control points are scattered on the
north and south alongside the ridge with
one more point in the middle of the
desert between the ridge and the allied
base
there's a strategic advantage to both
groups with the axis group on this map
being closer to the ridge point but the
allies receiving the benefit of the
desert points
as each team kind of vie for control in
navigating hostile territory as well
as factoring in the giant ridge as it
kind of dominates the region
taking the number six slot on our list
is battlefield 4's golmid railway
this map is also based on a real-life
location the golmed laza railway in
northwest
china the factions involved the russian
and chinese teams
engaged in battle set across a very
large grassy
and open area with a huge emphasis on
vehicular combat
we're talking tanks apcs jets
helicopters
you name it a few things that
distinguish this map from everything
else so far
since it is battlefield 4 means that the
map has a revolution of sorts
rather than be a decidedly one-time
event like other battlefield 4 maps
the main revolution on gold mid railway
is a mobile train that doubles down as a
capture point
the train moves only when held by a team
and slowly makes its way closer to the
team's deployment area
giving them a territorial advantage the
map has ieds that can be blown up by c4
or by following the wires to a laptop
found near roadways
and there's even an easter egg that
takes the form of a yeti
sure enough if you go to the north part
of the map and aim a rocket towards the
snowy mountain peak
you can hear a yeti scream in the
distance
[Music]
now we've reached the top 5 largest
battlefield maps of all time with the
zatar wetlands from battlefield 2
claiming the number 5 spot
the zatar wetlands serves the
battlegrounds between the usmc
and the mec the mec has its base whereas
the us forces
start on a carrier north on the water
there are airfields farms and even a
beach with a wide network of water
channels
connecting several small islands in the
center of the map
each island is connected through the
bridges and sprawls out across this
large expansive map
with plenty of capture points at areas
of interest such as
a natural gas station a village and even
a factory
this map appears in both battlefield 2
and 1942
but for here we'll focus on how highway
tampa operates in battlefield 2.
the map is located on a peninsula with
an incredibly desolate desert terrain
sprawling far out to encourage the use
of vehicles the capture points consist
of a refinery
a gas station a couple of villages two
checkpoints each in the west and south
locations of the map
and an airfield highway tampa was one of
the first free maps to be released for
battlefield 2
post launch battlefield 2 just keeps
making this list left and right and at
number 3 we got the dalian plant
the dalian plan is a large nuclear
facility that powers an electrical grid
in northern china
the map borders a large body of water
allowing for naval combat and the
terrain is fairly varied
the usmc starting point is on the uss
essex which is located east of the
mainland on the sea with
two spawn points one on the flight deck
and the other below where players can
take inflatable boats to the nearby
island or the main battleground
there are capture points at the docks
north of the large nuclear reactor
towers
as well as another dock south of the
towers where the main battle tanks can
spawn
maintenance buildings warehouses and the
main entrance are
also scattered across the region as the
pla faction tries to fight for control
from their spawn base which is set
on an airfield far west of the map
battlefield 3 has not been mentioned at
all in this list so far
but not to worry because the bandar
desert map ranks
super high at number 2. the map came
from the armored kill expansion and is a
small bay in iran
with the moderate desert central region
you've got residential areas close to
the shore
and an artillery base inland across the
desert the map has
rock outcroppings and has a large
highway running north and south
across the area there are also villages
construction sites some outposts
and another town up in the mountains
[Music]
so before people get mad at me in the
comments if we're talking pure conquest
then the bandar desert takes the throne
of being the largest battlefield map
however halvoy is by and large the
largest battlefield map in history so
far
thanks to the fact that it is the map
used for battlefield 5's firestorm mode
firestorm is the game's take on battle
royale and battle royale maps by design
needed an extremely large space to work
with
so yes hellboy is an outlier but
technically speaking it is the largest
map compare that to another large map
like hamada
and halvoy is 10 times its size there
are different types of terrain affected
by the climate
and landmarks on halvoy from industrial
sites small snow-capped towns
and even fishing villages or lake docks
the area is huge and kind of nice to
look at if you weren't being hunted down
by countless other players
it is so wild to think that despite
these maps being so
huge battlefield 2042 is expected to
have ridiculously large maps as well
we'll dive into all things battlefield
in the coming days so be sure to stick
around
but in the meanwhile let me know what
you think about battlefield's largest
map so far
thanks for watching
[Music]
you